well I think I think Reagan benefited a
doubt in some sense of hopelessness and
ineffectual Atia surrounded Carter by
the end but the achievement on the
arab-israeli arab-israeli treaty on the
egyptian-israeli treaty was not fully
appreciated politically at the time
these were the Israelis weren't
overjoyed about it there was a battle of
great move for them while it was seen in
some ways to have lost Iran or being
partly responsible for it he hadn't been
able to get the hostages back despite
making this the great cause of his final
year he said when the Soviets invaded
Afghanistan that his use of being
completely turned around and so that
made him look as if he really didn't
have a good grasp of what was going on
now cuz Reagan was completely different
to Carter in that Reagan never pretended
to have a grasp of detail that's not
what he he was known for but he did seem
to a offer a more positive message be
not be trying to confront America with
with its malaise in malaysia's of word
that car to use you could never imagine
Reagan using such a word about America
was all he was uplifting he offered a
clear message about American priorities
and dealing with evil and so on
interestingly he was extraordinarily
pragmatic and flexible over his
presidency and he wasn't by any means an
unyielding ideologue when it comes to
the particular problems he faced in some
ways Reagan with the iran-contra affair
when England how they insisted he would
never deal with countries like Iran when
he was working that much more closely
with the Iranians tolerated an opening
to Iran which one against everything
that he was saying so actually he dealt
with issues probably
more on a human and emotional level than
on an ideological level of many areas of
foreign policy but he but he had the
effect of making the Americans feel
quite good about what they were doing
and I think also had a great foreign
policy achievement in the in a way he's
Orton comes ain't broke the spirit of
the Soviet Union as an opponent of the
United States and it did so in a way in
the end that didn't rub the Soviet noses
in it he thought he was I think it was a
genuine foreign policy success on the
Middle East you can argue he went
through some pretty big failures but
because by the end of his presidency he
could also say that he'd humiliated the
Iranians to he better be partly
responsible with Iraq for them failing
to reach their objectives in there in
the iran-iraq war so the presidency
didn't end with an order of failure that
has ended earlier it might have been but
when a good at the end have laura's of
says well reagan was most polls will be
present and after Carter lessness swoop
this was quite noticeable the rest of
his administration was not so
pro-israeli and of course he came in
when beggin as well as Prime Minister
was taking a very strong line as a both
were the Palestinians and men in Lebanon
as well an invasion of Lebanon 82 to the
point that Reagan got really cross was
surprisingly cross know all sorts of
problems during the 80s between Israel
and the administration no Reagan never
lost his basically pro-israeli approach
he didn't move the arab-israeli conflict
on at all really only towards the end
and this was because of a chair of
shifts really in the Palestinian
position in the Intifada when
Schultz saw certain opportunities and
Secretary of State to somehow draw the
PLO into the negotiating process but up
to that point not a lot happened of
course Israeli politics was paralyzed
for much of the 80s and that was the
problem because they there was no
clear-cut government I think one of the
problems that has beset American Israeli
relations and which people who was
always demanding of the Americans that
put more pressure on Israel and so on is
just how weak in some ways a succession
of Israeli governments have been so
though they may have had prime minister
for foreign ministers who saw the need
to do to move the process forward they
never quite have the political strength
to do so another was reagan's particular
interest to try to challenge that as
opposed to his successor at the elder
Bush when he call him that who did right
and is well exist or isn't achieved a
strong vibrant economy and ma you know
my senses it probably will but I suspect
it'll be something very different
because I think states themselves will
all be very different it's really a
question of what you think else is going
to happen in the Middle East there's a
lot of failed States not in the sense of
collapsing in the heap failure but just
not doing for their people their
economies what states should do Syria
some extent around comes into that
character category most of the North
African states somewhere or other over
the next few years nothing is going to
be Israel there's going to be a major
eruption in one of these date you know
there's not a stable part of the world
it's very volatile so a lot of Israel
survival remains conditional and what
happens elsewhere there's a certain
amount that Israel can do for itself
the certain ways in which maybe it needs
to sort of reach out and think of
different ways of dealing with the
Palestinians easier said than done but a
lot of the key decisions are going to be
taken in other states and though
everybody's looking at around at the
moment you know that the real trouble
may come from somewhere else so I think
a lot of Israelis have got a sense of
historical anxiety they recognize that
just being able to defend your borders
or so friend suppress in some way
militants on the edge of your society is
one thing but rockets long-range rockets
are another thing altogether so there's
it an anxiety in Israel I'm not sure
they need to be that it anxious but they
are but in the end it depends on the
region the wider region sorting itself
out and this this is a whole region of
failures and many key respect Israel is
one of the more successful parts of it
so it's a regional challenge which if
the progress is made them then Israel
may be fine but I don't think states are
going to look the same in a hundred
years time so it may be a Jewish entity
in in that part of the world which is
thriving well looked after but doesn't
quite look like the state we see at the
moment
you